a semester semester is hoping to lead
the Green Party back into government
after 10 years in Germany's upcoming
election you grew up in a small town in
southern Germany
your parents were Turkish immigrants and
Muslims can you tell us how that
Christmas tree we can see behind us
arrived in your family living room no
Tiger Khan my parents put it there they
always found it natural to have it there
as we were living in Germany they didn't
want me to feel left out at Christmas
time plus my mother had grown up in
Istanbul with Armenian neighbors Jewish
neighbors and Greek neighbors and they
would always visit each other on their
respective religious holidays so on
Muslim holidays the Christian and Jewish
neighbors would pop by and vice-versa on
foot by Indian Christina my family was
pretty familiar with Easter and
Christmas you know you used to call
yourself an Anatolian Swabian or
southwestern German what about today
segunda Liga in that's a specified
profession I'm a politician but I'm
still a swadian stunt Oh sky coin the
term Anatolian Swabian after I was first
elected to Parliament in 1994 the media
the media had difficulty describing the
phenomenon I was called German Turk euro
Turk and even stretch litter to the
noodle dish from Baden württemberg where
I was born so before the media went
through the whole menu I thought it best
to come up with my own term because in
Toronto Natasha schwäbisch the first
words I heard in the delivery room were
the Swabian dialect although my memory
of that has faded a bit and Anatolian
actually stands for all the people he
used to live in Turkey and still do Jews
Christians Muslims Turks Kurds I didn't
want to be reduced to one ethnicity or
faith I wanted to speak for everyone
including people from other backgrounds
motivational mentioned Danish my Nair
confident but there was a moment in
elementary school where you felt you
were different undone you define in
terms of school grades definitely up
until fourth grade I always got a 5 one
of the lowest grades they wanted me to
repeat first grade it was standard
practice in West Germany back then for
pupils to go to secondary school after
4th grade I remember sitting in the back
row with the only other child with
immigrant parents a Portuguese boy and
the teacher asked what kind of school
we'd like to go to after 4th grade a
regular secondary school or grammar
school was esteemed geek Edith Bob Stein
you can you don't hope shooter they are
truly gymnasium my mother always wanted
me to go to grammar school as if you
could snap your fingers and make it
happen when the teacher asked who wanted
to go to a regular school I didn't
respond but when he said grammar school
I put my hand up he didn't see me at
first because I was at the back when he
did he burst into laughter and the whole
class laughed because the notion was so
funny on account of my background how
did you feel if I just got who Steve I
didn't find it so funny there are
certain things you never forget when one
day I'm on my deathbed I think I'll
still remember them laughing having to
be better than the rest in order to
succeed it's the same situation that
women face it certainly fueled my
ambition it's about showing people that
you can do or be something they think is
beyond you in my case Member of
Parliament then party chairman and now
Chancellor candidate for the elections
you decided to take German citizenship
in your teens today you're in favor of a
dual nationality law I myself I'm happy
with just one Passport it's hard enough
to keep track of one passport so should
people have to choose one or the other I
was born here I found it absurd not
having the nationality of the country
you're born in now you have a right to
nationality by birth which I
Ronna Klee was introduced by a
government I was part of so people like
me or at least our children are now
German by birth and that's a good thing
for all the shortcomings there's nothing
sacred for me about dual nationality
it's a polarizing issue in Germany the
kind highly community that door transia
some see it as a gift to humanity others
as a diabolical notion I say the
objective is naturalization it's better
for people who are permanent residents
to be German citizens because the
country's problems are better discussed
between citizens I see dual nationality
as a means to an end you stood by
admitted some Civic vanities come on
beat me a little bit but of course we
can talk about whether it's sensible for
someone who's been here for 30 or 40
years maybe third generation to be
voting in the Turkish referendum
shouldn't they be voting in German
elections yes the philistine Deutschland
obviously why is it that some people of
Turkish or Arab origin don't identify
with the country they've been living in
for so long whose fault is that
there's nothing unusual about
identifying with your ancestors country
a lot of Germans do too but consciously
turning down German citizenship enjoy
Jim Olsen leave the Germans living
abroad also have a connection to Germany
they watch DW to see what's happening
back home that's perfectly okay as
they're still speaking your native
language in addition to the local
language and they can practice their
religion if they have one this is where
any issues your children are facing are
to be resolved not by mr. Antoine or
wherever else here in Dorchester B&D
problem reduced for the india of tawa
year leave concrete terms in my opinion
the citizenship legislation should have
come earlier it took too long for us to
admit that we are a country of
immigration of course there are
consequences but we can't be naive there
are other countries that also
consciously don't want their citizens
here to integrate like turkey okay it
applies to mr. Putin - who wants German
Russians here to point their antenna
towards Moscow coalition
I'm talking of Turkey human rights
activist Peter stoner has just been
arrested there you posted this on
Twitter the German government's policy
on Turkey is a shambles due to a kind
Sheldon - what would you do differently
if you were in power as a Jewish big TVs
hindsight is always 20/20 but for me it
was a big mistake for Chancellor Merkel
to continue the same policy on Turkey as
the preceding social democrat green
government the EU was negotiating
Turkey's accession but that was a very
different turkey a forward-looking
Turkey that gave Christians more rights
and discussed the Kurdish question and
even the awkward question of Armenia was
the subject of relatively relaxed debate
in the Turkish Parliament women's rights
were advanced it was at a time when
turkey was on the right path when Merkel
was pressured by her own party into
saying a privileged partnership instead
of membership of Toki of apartheid is
that clearly get a partner shaft that
meekly to blame for the state that
Turkey is in no vanity could see it we
took him that would be simplifying
matters but she did play a part in
pro-reform forces being denied support
in Turkey that was a major mistake she
only rediscovered Turkey when she needed
the country during the refugee crisis
then she flew over almost every other
day which made everyone think the
Germans and Merkel need me I am a world
leader they will all come to me that was
a big mistake we should have made it
clear to air21 from the outset but he
now has all areas of Turkish society
firmly under his control is bad enough
the long arm of air Dewan has no
business here remember when it emerged
that turkish mosques were being used for
spying purposes and outing opposition
activists what happened nothing the
German government waited until all the
evidence had been destroyed that
wouldn't have happened on my watch
if you are in a position to make those
decisions what would you do differently
on the partnership with Turkey Tokai i
was divided with fun I leave the
accession talks where they are on ice
back of the freezer and if turkey does
introduce to death sentence as it is
announced then they'll stop completely
then they'll break off completely and
Turkey will have to leave the Council of
Europe then there's turkeys barring our
lawmakers from the NATO mission at Konya
airbase German parliamentarians have the
right to visit their army wherever they
are stationed any Parliament's are made
assess torture up condensation either so
darton
image that soon if everyone doesn't
relent there will be a response from
NATO in Brussels it's a NATO mission
I think it's wrong of the NATO
secretary-general to behave as if the
problem is about merkel vs air21 the
problem is air21 isn't acting in line
with nato everyone is behaving like a
ruffian in a bar who wants to beat
everyone up NATO has rules NATO has
shared values if air the one has an
issue with those values then he should
say so and NATO will have to end the
Konya missions do you know to you
conn-young would that mean rethinking
our NATO partnership with Turkey this is
idiots so then the response has to be by
NATO not us on our own but the Secretary
General is shirking his responsibilities
we in Germany have to say clearly that
we will not tolerate air21 trying to get
Turkish community organisations under
his control via the front organizations
he's invested so much money in here
right now as we speak
committees are being changed in one
mosque after another in Germany and the
people in favor of integration pushed
out the people who can speak German who
talked to their Christian pastors their
Jewish rabbis and their German neighbors
they're being replaced by people who
take their orders from Ankara we should
make a clear statement about this I
think now Merkel is too soft in this
respect we're now hearing the same
condemnation with Peter Steiner as we
did with Turkish German journalist denna
tootle who was arrested more than a
hundred days ago and is still in
detention it seems there's a lot of talk
but not much action on the ground
including from yourself
we can't send troops to Turkey to
liberate them how about a demonstration
the greens taking to the streets and
saying no way we don't want to become a
member of Turkey turkey wants to become
a member of the EU Turkish economy is in
serious trouble and is deeply unsettled
by everyone's isolationist policy German
tourist numbers have dropped turkey is
begging for economic aid from Germany so
I would say I fail to see how Turkey
qualifies for aid
I would tell German companies that
turkey is not a dependable location for
investments there's no rule of law
anyone can be arrested arbitrarily we
would turn the thumbscrews so that air
Dewan feels them butyl isn't rail stoick
nur is in police custody isn't it now
time to say instead of putting the EU
accession talks on the back shelf we
need to break them off refused to
disputes why it is my fear we'll be
seeing that all too soon beautiful the
one mistake we have to avoid is
overlooking the 50% plus of people in
Turkey who are against air21 as seen in
the referendum if it had been fair he
would have lost the other one wouldn't
win a fair election anymore he'd lose it
he lost the penultimate parliamentary
election which was arguably the last
semi fair one that taught him to prevent
elections being freely held opponents
who we can't defeat are locked away such
as the HDP Salah attend Amir Tesh
they're denied access to the media
imagine an election here in Germany
under those conditions
Wow Merkel on all stations 24/7 with
five minutes for the rest those de Mears
in jail and Martin Schultz gets beaten
up that's what's happening in Turkey
so what concrete steps would you suggest
our potential influence in Turkey is now
limited we did have options during the
EU accession talks and I think found
miracle made a mistake by relinquishing
that instrument view the forum and there
are rewards for reforms and for the
opposite potentially sanctions
chatzi you know under school Yahtzee but
America punished air21 when he did
something right and rewarded him when he
did something wrong but it's too late to
change that now bus when tomorrow ISM
Act does is it's over whom does the g20
summit looking forwards it's bad enough
that we're doing little or nothing on
Turkey but now air Dhawan wants to
establish turkey in Germany and I have
to say quite clearly that is not right
and I can prevent it I'd say mosques
here shouldn't get any more money from
Turkey in future and consequently
Germany has to make the commitment and
offer Turkish communities here financial
assistance to cut the umbilical cord for
instance I can say that I reject any
attempt to set up a parallel state here
a lot of opposition activists come to me
and say I'm not safe in Germany look at
the attempt to infiltrate the security
services I think we should make it
crystal clear that we won't stand for
that here in this respect Germany is a
bit naive or shouldn't be seen so naive
that sounds like a hard-line explain
things for our international audience if
you are to be in the next government it
would be as a junior coalition partner
traditionally the junior coalition
partner takes the post of foreign
minister and that post would surely have
its appeal for you put that out there
our Swabian modesty says first we have
to win an election and then once you've
conducted successful negotiations you
look at who will get which post and of
course it's the people who led the party
into the election who have a big say in
matters or indeed the final say but
first we have to win the election
because what mission have mrs. Agnes
inside of a discontent but we'd still
like to talk about a few of your other
positions for the benefit of our
international audience
Venezuela is a big story right now
we cover it daily here on DW do you feel
that the German government should be
more involved in this conflict the
Bundesliga on indecently Island as a
finger mom was Maduro is guilty of awful
human rights abuses he ignores
Parliament's decisions and the people
are paying for it to the fupas sighs
this is not a poor country it's one of
the richest countries in the world - ah
but instead of investing in
infrastructure and modernizing the oil
industry Hugo Chavez fought elections
with gifts what I find most appalling is
that our own Left Party still justifies
Chavez with their left-wing romanticism
when I was younger I was interested in
the Opposition in El Salvador I was for
the Sandinistas but I was 15
there can be no excuses for supporting
this kind of coup from above from a
president who legitimizes his power
through force and who is wrecking the
country I want to see clear criticism
here and typically I'm hearing very
little on the issue from my left-wing
friends in other South American
countries the Lincoln in America shows
the Avena SH for my appointment for the
Lincoln in London Sudamericana Lyndon
destroyed the unsession
what would you say we have to move on
what would you say on the issue of
Russia this past year it's similar there
are a lot of people whose criticism of
human rights issues is defined by
whether or not it's the Americans at
fault it's the kingdom of ikana you have
to be against human rights violations
regardless of who commits them whether
the culprits have American support or
link to Russia the same applies to
Venezuela and there are some on the Left
who defined their version of human
rights by saying when supposed left
wingers locked people away and murder
them it's not as bad as when the gringos
are doing it been stealing gold that has
nothing to do with my party's stance we
don't have any pet dictators when
protein occupies part of Ukraine he
should be sharply criticized and here I
support Mirko she was right to get
Europe to impose sanctions on Russia
does she know who Paul Gauguin is yet
visiting Muslim mom should there be more
sanctions if pressure moves in the right
direction it should be rewarded if
Russia makes the wrong move
there must be different consequences
currently she has admitted to Russian
troops having occupied the Crimea we're
currently seeing an escalation in the
eastern Ukraine that's why I see no
reason to lift sanctions on the contrary
I think the sanctions should be
tightened Russia is now hinting at the
presence of Russian troops there to
their reports of forced labor I see no
reason to reward Russia for that you see
kindest most and a few ballooned to
Germany what I wanted to know while
preparing for the interview was what the
greens and yourself are fighting for
today of us came from de Lune annoyed to
Philistines none of us though we can do
the same things I joined the party for
that was November 1981 when I was 15
back then we were the only party
addressing the environment and
sustainability and we've achieved a lot
Germany is the only country to commit to
phasing out nuclear power we convinced
the mainstream parties to join our
effort to see this but the co2 emissions
have not fallen in the last eight years
Germany is the world's biggest producer
of lignite there's still a lot of work
to do
Frau Merkel signed the Paris climate
Accord and for me that means the greens
are also committed to it so I feel it is
our duty to make Germany the world's
leader in climate protection we've
leased it does via its torch land they
might still be unbeatable kima shoots wh
can defiantly you explain your party's
falling poll ratings is it because of
your candidacy the greens aren't in such
a good position in fact you're now going
up we had dropped to 6% and now it's up
to 8 in the 2013 election the Greens
posted 8.4 percent the last survey had
you at 8% what sent you know Dinah's
even so goblin oil one has is at 9% and
in my native button Burton burg we're at
14% up from 11%
I know the job description of a party
chairman from Swabia is to never be
satisfied and always push for more but
I'd rather have the poor ratings at the
start and then improve in the 2013
general election we had great opinion
poll ratings but ended up with 8.4
percent now it's the other way around so
you're satisfied as I just said I'm
never satisfied I always want more and
we're improving right now and why is
that
but apart from being here at DW I'm
attending a lot of campaign events I was
recently in a beer tent with 700 people
in Bavaria tweeted but what are you
doing to get the message across in
general do you like touring the country
the election won't be decided in
downtown Berlin it will be decided in
all the local newspapers and radio
stations just like in other democracies
there's a kind of bubble in downtown
Berlin that applies both to US
politicians and journalists I'm where
the election is decided
elsewhere in Germany and Ahmedabad we've
won the environment issue enough know
the big issue is also Europe president
Mike Cronin of France has offered to set
up a climate union with Germany to make
progress on carbon pricing in my opinion
this is a unique opportunity to make
Europe stronger together with Makonnen
I'd say yes and I'm sure the Chancellor
agrees except she doesn't dare make the
move because of the right-wing and her
party we would be resolute and then
there's the integration issue I want a
country where you're not judged by where
you're from but where you're headed
regardless of whether people have
Russian Turkish or Swabian roots
everyone should be part of this new US
and I made it to that you frequently
criticized for our miracle what would
you have to do to get your vote issue it
is availing there's yeah whose least if
you mocked she has done some things
right I always try to be fair I praised
her earlier for the sanctions on Russia
and keeping Europe together and we
supported that is where I see
the major deficit is the environment xiv
when it comes to the headlines
she's world-class when I see Trump or
the brexit vote
she's a glowing figure but once you
scratch beneath the surface Germany is
not a leader on climate protection co2
emissions have not fallen eight years so
when we go to the g20 summit wanting to
get progress from Trump but come back
and D handed then it was for nothing I
was a bit lien on content with the snake
storage Germany can do better we have a
great medium-sized sector and research
infrastructure we have a lot of startups
making good money from environmental
innovations we need a government that
rediscovers its faith in Germany
strength as a business location and that
environmental and economic interests are
one in the same and that's what my party
stands for you did a photo shoot for
Ghana magazine with classic German
motifs you can see it in the photo
behind us what your eyes is still German
today that he's here fukushi the photo
shoot had all these stereotypes the
crossword the bathroom you can't see the
white songs for me Germany is firstly a
country that enjoys great respect in the
world even if the made in Germany brand
has now gotten a few scratches also
Berlin's ongoing new airport saga for
you Stuttgart the railway station there
is an embarrassing issue the diesel
emissions scandal - I'm annoyed about
the impact and health terms but also
because so many consumers bought a car
in good faith only to find what was
promised was a lie
three sentences what is German unit
ocean is in Germany is a fantastic
country with a strong democracy we did a
great job with the refugees which many
other countries are envious self-insure
there are problems but we have
everything we need to solve them but you
helped us the others have and Busta
polka music will bloom it's Toulouse do
you have a typical German quality do you
look at Iraq where I was born mainly
Protestant
but the neighboring town is Catholic and
right there you have different traits
there's no such thing as the Germans or
the Turks there is no uniform Protestant
or Catholic or Muslim we're all
different which is great three concrete
adjectives stereotypes workmanship
German engineering diligence and order
I'm talking to my friends of Turkish
origin I say don't combine Turkish
efficiency with German hospitality it
should be the other way around since we
door Augusta 4 inch shaft so some links
to Levinsky final question
imagine having to spend a month on a
desert island and you have to take
someone along in order to survive you
have to pick one of your rivals for
chancellor right I have to pick one one
of them me the fish not so if I can
connect or from America I'm happily
married because he used to be a
librarian and have a bookstore so we
could talk about all the great books
I've never had time to read I hope he
would tell me a lot about them the
ability myth and I didn't Busha at
seeing the initial is now the Social
Democrats Martin shorts with Chema Samir
on a desert island and a report when we
get back thank you very much for talking
to us
[Music]
you
[Music]